hello I'm Mindy Kaling and I am Dame
Emma Thompson hmm I'm an extraordinary
talented young writer and performer I am
a two-time Oscar winning actress
activist mother mother of dragons now
I'm making things up and will answer
some questions that we have in this cute
little cop what's the best piece of
advice someone told you that you still
live by to this day we're always laugh
in the face of disaster that's a great
one my piece of advice is before you can
say I love you you must be able to say I
it's a riddle it's just that before you
can say to somebody else that you love
them you need to be able to know who you
are and what you still
absolutely because love romantic love is
generally a projection of the impossible
onto the other person who and so it's a
very difficult space and you need to be
very careful with it I think that's very
good advice
very good advice as a teenager in 2019
how do I not succumb to peer pressure
but also not come off as lean that's
like saying how do you lose I mean I
think that the problem is everyone else
does just be yourself but then what if
your self is dorky to other people it's
very hard yeah I think you just have to
wait it out absolutely trust your
instincts they are your sword and your
shield and they will never let you down
the things that you really feel inside
yourself don't crush them down because
you think that other people will think
that their name but if you could stick
to that you'll be safer I was moved by
that like Katherine's character in late
night she's strong but it's described as
being mean and abrasive how do you
handle being a boss lady when so few
people except women in powerful
positions so many of the adjectives that
are used to describe a successful leader
are attributed to men mmm it decisive is
the most common because I'm very
decisive which would be termed bossy in
you know that's what people who say
about women so the way I handle it is I
kind of let my work speak for itself if
you kind of ignore what the other people
are thinking and focus on the work and
the work is good
then people don't think of you as bossy
they think of the OSHA was decisive
because the product was good and
remember that personal power that is to
say your character the nature of your
character which is built on every action
of every day the nature of that is your
real power and that's the power that
really counts and smoke will get you
through life how do you handle rejection
and stay confident in yourself
especially in an industry where you hear
no way more often than you hear yes how
do I handle rejection very poorly
actually and it's something that when
you feel it enough you get more used to
it and even it sort of feels less bad
the other thing that has helped me with
handling rejection is I'm always working
on several different things that I care
a lot about so at anytime if I feel
rejection and one thing I'm like okay it
stings and it never doesn't sting but I
have other things that I'm working on
that I feel equally passionate about you
know I've had some rejections of work
that have been genuinely I would say
quite damaging in the sense that they've
said they've made me feel that I better
not do this anymore I could not do this
but I think Mindy's right if you're
creative and something's been rejected
you must then turn and just start again
a bit like getting back on the horse
don't it not everything you do will be
good however good you are not everything
you do will be good and also failure is
a vital importance to your development
as a creative person or was any person
really what's the great saying that you
learn more from your failures and from
your successes it is still true very
true what advice do you have for people
trying to navigate an office romance or
relationship don't ya just don't because
it will end in tears it'll end with you
in the Box room wherever you keep the
computer cartridges that's all not this
relationship
I'm not shocked but that's like okay
fair enough I did it twice but the first
time didn't work out so well did it
No so shoosh how do you go about
breaking up with friends when the
relationship has turned toxic that's a
good one that's a good one I think the
way that I learned I used to be young
and dramatic and need to have a big talk
and we need to stop hanging out and what
I realized was that drifting away is the
way to do it I think that having a
confrontation is probably the least
helpful because it makes it more
dramatic and more heightened and you
feel like you're inextricably drawn
together because there's a passion of
the fight so I find that when I am with
a toxic friendship that I just have to
stop showing up for things cancelling
plans but I was being cheerful and happy
about it while I slowly enjoy and I
think as someone who's very old it might
be useful to be able to know that not
all friendships last that friendships
like books or words or feelings they
sometimes are appropriate for a
particular time in your life and then
they become inappropriate and if you're
anything like me you think I've got to
do everything I can to save this
friendship because you feel bad and
actually you don't have to do that you
can look at the friendship and say okay
what what's this person bringing to me
are they making me happy in any way and
if they are well then you work at work
continue if they're not because we're
asking about particularly about toxic
friendships then you need to just drift
away like Molly's character and late
night a lot of women slash women of
color are what a few if not the only
ones in their office how do you navigate
being in a room where no one looks like
you at least in TV comedy writing
world's growing West West common which
is nice than it was once it's you can't
change anyone really you can't change
the people you're with you could only
learn from the experience you're in and
then hope that in success you can create
a different one I was the only woman and
the only person of color on a show but
that was a place where people were very
open-minded but that won't always be the
case the real way to get through
something like that is to work hard
separately on your own things so that
you can succeed and create a different
environment I mean I did it for years
and all the boys thought that was
fantastic for me because I was paying
attention and so I was made to feel bad
about the fact that I had no one else
who was like me in the room you have to
be quite self-reliant to actually so in
a sense I suppose you can look at it as
quite a creative space to be in because
you really are forced to develop
yourself what advice you have for
someone trying to be an actress
coming from a family that's telling you
to do something more realistic you could
just pretend that you work in retail and
then just carry on do your audition
since I'd say you know it's it's really
great in the shoe department at Macy's
and and that'll shut them up you don't
have to tell them everything you know
sometimes being creative is if you're if
you're surrounded by people going oh for
heaven sake get a grip you're never
gonna earn a living you can just sort of
lie the great thing about people who are
successful as actors is I would say a
majority of them did not have people
supporting them I feel like we should
send out machetes but some responses god
sorry I'm currently stuck in a cycle of
perpetual distraction Oh what do you
mean any advice on how to get out of
this creative slump and start writing
again I'm inspired by terrible things so
what I like to do is mine feeling
creatively
humdrum whatever as I like to just go
see a terrible movie and I feel this so
what some of you might visit disaster
zones no I quit jitter in the Mozambique
like well wait I've had a really good
idea maybe that would work but no not
that kind of terrible I like to see
things that are bad because I it makes
me feel like well I could do that so
much better and I find it very inspiring
weeding any magazine about the creative
endeavor that you're involved in just
don't ever do that because it's you
always think everyone's making much
better things than you and there's way
too many films being made and why are
you even bothering so it's good to avoid
avoid that I think to keep yourself
creative you
have to go and walk the streets how do
you get over a breakup
especially when the breakup wasn't your
decision arson hmm burn that house down
immediately if there are curtain rods
take off the ends and push prawns into
the space and they will never ever be
able to get rid of the smell all know
where the smell is coming from
[Music]